here's the man who's dealt the latest
setback to Volkswagens already tarnished
reputation
Herbert's Gilbert's bought a used VW
containing the cheating software which
made the car look like it was less
polluting than it really was his case
potentially means that he's 70 thousand
others could also ask for at least some
of their money back
Goswami it's a pity that of all the
companies it was Volkswagen which
committed the fraud VW could have had it
easier how they admitted this from the
outset and said we cheated we are sorry
and we will compensate the affected
owners with no questions asked that
certainly would have not damaged their
image quite the contrary
move - Rashaad the fraud was on an
industrial scale some 11 million cars
fitted with the cheating device was an
astonishing revelation inside a company
which prides itself on its environmental
advances and inside Germany a country
which sees itself as leading the way
against climate change hugely
embarrassing this ruling means VW has to
offer to buy back cars it's sold based
on their current mileage arguably less
damaging to the country's finances than
to its reputation they have of course to
pay compensation for the problems that
they caused in the past and they paid a
lot of that money however now I feel
they are in a situation to look more
into the future because see VW is a very
important company and has a lot of
employees in Germany and we need that PW
had already been given a corporate file
of over a billion dollars and the two
executives in charge of the scandal have
spent millions more buying their way
outs of criminal charges if this is the
beginning of the end of the scandal it
can't come soon enough
for Volkswagen Lawrence Lea al Jazeera